à ce moment là de la compétition ils
sont ex-aequo marque thermale et
christophe lagneau enchaîne les parcours
sans rien perdre de leur concentration
au ball-trap le parcours de chasse est
une discipline emblématique huit postes
de tir différents répartis sur un
terrain de 12 hectares afin de
représenter comme en pleine nature les
différentes végétation hébergeant le
gibier les plateaux sont envoyées aussi
bien en l'air hauteur d'oiseaux au ras
du sol pour simuler le déplacement d'un
lapin concentration vigilance et
rapidité
il faut rester à l'affût qu'il faut
analyser une trajectoire il faut savoir
l'analyse et savoir l'attiré et sur un
parcours de chasse et a énormément de
trajectoires différentes en fonction des
postes c'est un des plateaux
donc voilà tout ça c'est de la technique
c'est du savoir on n'a pas forcément
et pourtant christophe lagneau
enchaînera deux sans faute ce matin son
adversaire lui non plus n'a pas tremblé
marc permal a déjà remporté trois fois
la compétition mais il sait qu'il faut
se méfier d'une baisse de régime
enfin le parc où notre point de vue
c'est la fatigue d'un jeu que la
pression de temps en temps ils auront
peut-être un jour à redouter la jeune
génération montante
cette année sur cette triangulaire
antilles guyane cinq jeunes cadets et
juniors sont venus tenter leur chance à
l'image de loïc heures liée sans doute
intimidé pour sa première journée il
impressionne lors de ses derniers
parcours en s'approchant du sans faute
et si compliqué de ce qui a beaucoup de
tuyaux guadeloupe et guyane elle-même
maman tu n'y connais beaucoup ce qu'il
ya beaucoup de pression cette donation
était beaucoup beaucoup plus simple pour
moi j'ai pu à aligner des scores assez
irrégulier qu est constamment ailleurs
mais ça a été ça a été mieux aujourd'hui
loïc termine meilleur jeune de la
compétition
christophe chanut au troisième devant
marc faire mal 4e une compétition
remportée par deux ex-aequo daniel
dervin et david petit